Toronto said that world war three has
never been closer World War III has
never been closer than it is right now
we need to clean house of all of the war
mongers and America last globalists in
the Deep State the Pentagon the state
department and the National Security
industrial complex one of the reasons I
was the only president in Generations
who didn't start a war is that I was the
only president who rejected the
catastrophic advice of many of
Washington's generals bureaucrats and
the so-called diplomats who only know
how to get us into conflict but they
don't know how to get us out for decades
we've had the very same people such as
Victoria Newland and many others just
like are obsessed with pushing Ukraine
toward NATO not to mention the state
Department's support for uprisings in
Ukraine these people have been seeking
confrontation for a long time do you
agree